welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man 3 the follow-up to
far from homecoming december 2021
just electrified nerd's teeth straight
by confirming that
electro jamie foxx's villain from the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man 2 in
2014
is returning in this third film in the
mcu
alongside tom holland peter parker with
zendaya mj marisa tomei aunt may
jacob battle on ned and tony revolori
flash thompson coming back as well
electro coming back was a move we saw
coming less than gwen stacy saw the
ground
but here we are in an age where anything
anything is weirdly possible
these are confusing times i'm gonna
explain why this
is happening and what deeper
implications this has
on a possible live-action spider-verse
that is looking increasingly likely
with tobey maguire andrew garfield in
hell even a miles morales
in this increasingly insane crossover
spoiler warning in case any of my
predictions are right but again i don't
think any of us could have predicted
this [ __ ]
while elektro might not have been at the
top of everyone's favorite list then the
news is a bit shocking
sorry this is the latest move in a
strategy years in the making by sony to
make
its spider-verse increasingly
intertwined with the mcu
we all remember jk simmons returning as
jay jonah jameson in the post-credits
scene in spider-man far from home
here's the real blockbuster brace
yourselves you might want to sit out
and of course simmons memorably played
jameson in the sam rainey toby maguire
spider-man film
crap crap mega crap i'll give you 200
bucks for all of them
so his return in the mcu was then the
most
brazen crossover yet by sony from the
rainy verse
to the universe of the avengers a nice
thick
in what we have described as an ever
expanding live-action spider-verse
like the animated spider-verse and into
the spider-verse but with
flesh jacked flesh
actually very recently jk simmons shed
light on that cameo
explaining how he and that movie's
producers had
long conversations about how to
differentiate this jameson from the
jameson he played in the rainy films
simmons wanted it to be different but
the sony team really wanted it to be the
same raimi
verse character and simmons lacked that
the compromise was making him bald
clarifying
so j jonah jameson either lost his hair
in the last few years or he was wearing
a hair piece the whole time i don't know
you pick
the hilarious truth to that being jk
simmons wore a hair piece as jim jameson
in those rainy films
the man has been bald since his peanut m
m days uh
santa but hey i totally get why jay
jonah jameson would be so angry
it must be hard to be a big time
newspaper man and have to deal with
losing your hair jimmy fox electro has
to deal with the receding hairline too
these guys could fight back against that
male pattern baldness with
keeps thanks to keeps for sponsoring
this video two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are 35 years
old with keeps it is easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss to help you keep the hair that
you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy
and you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you can do it all from the
comfort of your own home
you meet with a doctor online and they
ship the treatment right to you
every three months so that you don't
have to wait in line at the pharmacy
find out why keep says more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair you can do something about it for a
limited time go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description to receive
50 off your first order but jameson
wasn't the only cross spider-verse twist
far from home included an easter egg on
a wrestling poster listing
bonesaw mcgraw macho man randy savage's
wrestler toby peter fought in the first
ringy film
based on crusher hogan from the comics
but the name bones on mcgraw was
original to that film
making that poster an inter-universal
book
similarly sony's doing some weird [ __ ]
by casting michael keaton vulture from
the mcu spider-man homecoming
in the sony vs morbius film coming next
year
a film that also features graffiti
depicting spider-man with the word
murderer implying the scapegoating that
was done for the character then far from
home but
this particular spider-man has the suit
of the rainy era spider-man
technically the one from the loading
screen of the video games and then there
was a set photo for morbius showing a
print ad from the daily bugle
asking where is spiderman but that bugle
logo isn't the mcu
infowars design it's the old prince
newspaper version from the raimi films
and weirdest of all all the way back in
2004 sam raimi
included a marvel joke with j jonah
jameson doctor strange
that's pretty good but it's taken which
prophetically
whipped into the future in which 15
years later raymie
would be hired to direct doctor strange
2 for marvel
now in the amazing spider-man 2 electro
was last seen using electrical grid
columns to sound out nursery rhymes but
hey the visuals looked pretty sick right
peter and gwen ended up using the grid
to overload electro with electrical
energy and his head clip
blinked down to nothing but you know
when you're made up of electrical energy
i'm sure you could just wake up in a
dorm room power strip it's science
the amazing spider-man 2 ended by
setting up a sinister six sequel in this
universe with harry osborne goblin
vulture
dock rhino mysterio and kraven the
hunter but that movie was
scrapped when sony struck a deal with
marvel to share the spider-man character
in the mcu but what i find interesting
is
with its mcu spider-man films sony has
more or less clung
to that original sinister six plan
vulture was the primary villain of
spider-man homecoming
mysterio and far from home a separate
craven the hunter movie was just
announced and now sony's pretending
electro never left her fuse boxes
so that brings us to the two major
implications of this
electro news with craven now confirmed
as a character in a separate spider-man
spin-off as opposed to the primary
spider-man 3 villain we thought he was
going to be
this makes it almost certain that
spider-man 3 will be
a sinister six movie and based on sony's
scheming
that sinister six lineup will include
michael keaton adrian toomes vulture
jamie foxx electro and jared leto morby
is the living vampire and then
underneath those three there appear to
be a bunch of wild card options possibly
michael mando matt gargan scorpion
or bokeem woodbine herman schultz
shocker was still active at the end of
homecoming some theories suggest jake
gyllenhaal quentin back mysterio could
still be alive after far from home
of course tom hardy eddie brock venom or
woody harrelson cleared his cassidy
carnage
but i'm betting we will see a female doc
ock as we saw with olivia octavius and
into the spider-verse maybe also a new
norman osborne or harry osborne goblin
that could tie into that weird flash
subplot and far from home with his
neglectful parents
some of these new names could be
introduced in morbius or venom let there
be carnage coming out next year
but jamie foxx electro returning is
going to require some explanation
because even general audiences are going
to be a bit thrown to see the villain
who stand andrew garfield now zapping a
completely different peter parker i mean
jk simmons coming back was one thing but
at least he didn't appear in the more
recent andrew garfield films other than
a couple angry emails the only way
elektra coming back makes sense is if we
expand the live action universe into
the spider-verse the vast web of life
and destiny as it's known in the comics
an inter-dimensional crossroads that
links earth 616 where peter parker is
spider-man with earth 1610 where miles
morales has become spider-man after
peter's death
also with earth 65 where gwen stacy
becomes spider woman after peter becomes
a lizard we saw all of this in the
animated film but
sony must be planning to contextualize
this in the live
action world either using the mcu
quantum realm alternate timeline logic
or maybe the sparkle portals of doctor
strange or the reality resetting of
wanda in one division
or maybe their own unique aesthetic
specific to spider-man
personally i hope it's a sticky patch of
webbing that tears open on random
surfaces kind of like those riffs to the
upside down and stranger things
because interdimensional travel should
not be clean and slick
it should require awkward forceful
shoving
that ruins your clothes so that dumb
kids like peter parker won't hop
dimensions all the time
crap and the best way to make electro
makes sense would be to do what into the
spider-verse did go
all out with this crossover cast toby
maguire cast andrew garfield as
alternate spider-man alongside tom
holland in this story and when
they cross over into the mcu earth 19999
jamie foxx electro could spill in with
that convergence as well
and the same could be said for whatever
universe morbius is in
really i think the ultimate bottom line
with a live-action spider-verse is the
potential introduction
of a live-action miles morales and a
live-action gwen stacy we know miles
morales exists in the mcu based off of
that one line from his uncle aaron
i don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood i got a nephew who live
here yeah sorry miles
i'm not going to make it yeah i'm just
stuck so it's also possible that gwen
stacy exists somewhere around here and
i'm not talking about that extra with
the hot topic skirt and in-game
look folks we are going to be talking
about this a lot more going forward you
can discuss these theories with me in
the meantime
on new rockstar's official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.com new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram ideaboss follow
new rockstars thank you for watching and
if you are an
eel in the mcu you better look out
vengeance is coming
i'm vengeance
[Music]
you